alors écoutez c'est pas péjoratif ce que
j'allais le dire mais les policiers
comme les jardins ont sonné les bons
soldats et je peux vous assurer pour
avoir pris quelques informations
évidemment avant cette émission que une
grande majorité de policiers sont déjà
vaccinés
ça c'est clair et ils ont effectivement
une mission particulière puisqu'ils sont
au contact des gens souvent à
l'extérieur d'ailleurs et armand je
dirais à l'intérieur si donc dans les
commissariats pour des plaintes des
autres n'est pas au contact direct comme
peuvent l'être les les soignants qui
sont en plus dans des lieux
particulièrement exposés
donc pour pour votre information et que
qu'on le sache bien effectivement le des
policiers sont en grande majorité votent
ils les policiers les gendarmes et comme
tous les français de façon plus générale
on est des gens responsables
voilà si les policiers les gendarmes
sont vaccinés aujourd'hui c'est parce
qu'ils ont fait le choix de le faire
pour certains d'entre eux parce que
l'état avait mis à disposition des doses
de vaccin pour je sais qu'il est un
week-end spécial vaccination enseignants
et police et le jour j avais pas de dose
de vaccination donc une fois de plus ce
n'est pas l'état qui montre l'exemple
c'est les policiers les gendarmes
la vaccination est un acte médical un
acte médical ce qui veut dire qu'en
fonction de la santé qu'on a
lâche qu'on a les l'état de santé qu'on
peut avoir
elle peut être bénéfique ou au contraire
peut être contre-productive en fonction
du type de vaccin qu'on va avoir
il serait judicieux d'être conseillés
voilà mais à partir de là les gens sont
grands sont responsables ce qui serait
bien c'est qu'on ait tant de cette
responsabilité à tous les français comme
c'est fait pour les policiers les
gendarmes ce qui représente la santé
publique ces infirmiers ses médecins
tous ces gens qui nous sauve qui nous
qui nous et qui nous protège en même
temps quelque part doivent je pense
comprendre tout au moins pour la partie
qui ne souhaitent pas se faire vacciner
qu'il faut le faire parce que eux-mêmes
sont très exposés et eux-mêmes
exposeront nécessairement ceux qui sont
les plus faibles ceux qui sont les plus
faibles
généralement c'est ce que nous
retrouvons dans les ehpad dans les
hôpitaux effectivement puisque mon
bataillon l'hôpital lorsqu'on est malade
donc je pense que très sincèrement je ne
vois pas la scission qui puisse y avoir
entre une administration et une autre je
crois que les gens sont assez
intelligents pour comprendre ça mais je
pense que c'est une véritable nécessité
pour le monde médical d'être vacciné
parce que ce sont eux qui sont sur le
pont et qui sont engagés pour
votre santé ce gouvernement à inventer
quelque chose d'assez incroyable lunch
totalitaire lunch et pour inciter les
gens et il incite les gens et si les
gens ne sont pas cités il oblige donc
c'est un non sens et c'est complètement
aberrant
donc en fait ce soir laisse le choix
sont laisse pas le choix non peuvent à
faire entre les deux qui sont en train
de subir la deuxième chose c'est que les
soignants ont été en première ligne
pendant le premier confinement ils ont
mérité des applaudissements aujourd'hui
on veut leur forcer la main
la deuxième chose aussi c'est que moi je
suis pas personnel médical les personnes
médicale je pense qu'ils sont mieux
placés pour savoir ce qui est bon pour
eux au niveau vaccinale ou pas donc
effectivement à faire une catégorie à
part
et la deuxième chose c'est qu'on a pu
voir avec ce gouvernement c'est qu'il
ment régulièrement il y aura pas de
passe vaccinale obligatoire le passage
final sept ans il y aura pas de vaccins
au fur et à mesure de cette crise on
change le discours au fur et à mesure et
des fois ça va très vite c'est des fois
dans la même journée
donc c'est juste peut-être un prémice à
quelque chose d'autre je pense que le
gouvernement a géré des situations qui
était très complexe et je pense que
l'ensemble des pays d'europe
aussi ces problématiques même s'il y
aura un moment donné on a dit qu'ils
avaient des pays qui ont plus vacciner
que la france etc
moi je pense que le président m'a kong
s'adapte s'adapte aux informations que
lui tendent les les sachants comme on
dit les grands professeurs qui sont
autour de lui qui travaille et qui
collait suspense un peu plus le domaine
que nous devons et je dirais que le
président même s'il impose ce vaccin de
façon draconienne à travers le pass et
le pcr payant si c'est nécessaire je
pense qu'on va vers des choses beaucoup
plus positive et surtout trouver une
ferme une issue à cette problématique du
comité tout simplement
aujourd'hui ce que je constate c'est ce
que je retiens de ce discours c'est un
état qui veut imposer sans en assumer
les conséquences de ses choix
dire qu'en fait il dit vous devez faire
ça aux français vous devez vous vacciner
par contre si un souci ce ne sera pas
moi le responsable aujourd'hui on a à
l'état qui affiche et les opinions
politiques les opinions religieuses les
opinions syndicales les opinions
personnelles et philosophiques
aujourd'hui il veut mettre sur la place
publique le secret médical ou où ça va
s'arrêter où ça va s'arrêter à lorsque
c'est nécessaire ou pas aujourd'hui par
exemple l'angleterre sortie de crise 19
juin 19 juillet pardon voilà on sort
d'autres choses ont mal aux contresens
de tout ce que font les autres
pendant que les policiers espagnols
distribuer à 10 millions
masquer la police française faisait 10
millions de contrôles d'attestation
qu'est-ce qui protège le plus d'un virus
la distribution de masques la
distribution de contraventions
je pose la question donc on a fait comme
me disait le ms certains pays ont
utilisé la crise sanitaire pour faire du
sécuritaire appliquer des mesures
autoritariste donc voilà nous sommes sur
quelque chose de la gestion de masse
n'est pas du tout sur la gestion humaine
et c'est ça que je retiens de ce
discours malheureusement